bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches et
bonne année à tous à tous sauf à ceux
qui nous ont pourri la vie depuis deux
ans
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée à cette
semaine aux états unis entre l'inflation
la menace d'un défaut de paiement la
croissance qui ralentit ou encore le
taux de chômage qui stagne l'économie
des etats-unis' a connu des jours
meilleurs doit-on pour autant
s'inquiéter pour l'économie américaine
c'est la question qui va nous occuper
ces vingt prochaines minutes pour en
parler olivier delamarche bonjour
olivier josseaux à vos côtés pierre
bentata bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université aix-marseille
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci allez on
va commencer à part un aperçu global de
l'économie américaine c'est avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
outre atlantique ces dernières semaines
les motifs d'inquiétude pour l'économie
sont nombreux en premier lieu il y à
l'inflation en novembre elle a connu un
pic de +6 8% sur un an du jamais vu
depuis 1982 et par rapport à octobre une
augmentation des prix plus haute que ce
qui était prévu par les économistes
que l'avocat ziane forcément des baisses
sur la consommation même pour le
sacro-saint black friday qui a vu son
chiffre global baisser de 1,3 pour cent
selon adobe addai ticks à peine 8,9
milliards de dollars dépensés jusqu'à
présent cette inflation été qualifiée de
transitoire par la réserve fédérale
américaine mais fin novembre jérôme
powell fraîchement réélu à la présidence
de la fed a reconnu avoir fait une grave
erreur finalement cette inflation ne
serait pas passagère et pourrait être
persistante dans ce contexte la reprise
économique ralentie aux états unis sur
la croissance d'abord après avoir
dépassé les 6% les deux premiers
trimestres elle n'a été que de 2,1 pour
cent au troisième
et puis sur le chômage le département du
travail a déclaré que les emplois dans
le secteur privé non-agricole avait
augmenté de 210000 en novembre bien
moins que les 570 mille emplois
d'octobre selon les chiffres officiels
le chômage américain serait de 4,2 pour
cent il n'a pas encore retrouvé son
niveau historiquement bas de février
2020 à 3 5% à cette époque l'amérique
était loin de se douter que deux mois
plus tard elle subirait une faune d'amy
et un effondrement de l'économie avec un
chômage qui crèverait le plafond pour
atteindre 15% olivier tous ces chiffres
que l'on vient de voir que l'on vient
d'entendre ce qu'il vous paraissent
inquiétants
bon mais on est en plein déclassement de
l'économie américaine mais ça ça dure
depuis une bonne une bonne quinzaine
d'années et on est évidemment loin de
l'image idyllique qu'il voudrait bien
donner donc oui il ya eu un peu de
rebond de croissance mais qui était
logique quand vous fermez vous rouvrez
bain tout d'un coup vous avez un petit
peu plus de croissance
mais on retombe on voit qu'on très bien
qu'on est en train de retomber sur le la
croissance potentielle américaine est
qui qui est loin évidemment des 6% et
pour la bonne et simple raison que
aujourd'hui nom de croissance que de
croissance de la dette c'est à dire que
ils financent cette espèce de reprise
mais qui est une reprise tout à fait
fictif je dirais donc sur les chiffres
du chômage là aussi c'est exactement la
même chose que quand monsieur macron
vous dit que on est à 8% de chômage
c'est pareil c'est à dire sont des
chiffres qui sont des chiffres marketing
politique
qui font couler beaucoup d'encre mais on
est loin du plein emploi aux états unis
vous avez des masses de personnes qui
sont sorties de la population active et
donc qui sont sortis aussi des
statistiques donc le taux de chômage est
beaucoup plus important que les 4% et
puis et puis en dernier lieu sur
sur les revirements de monsieur powell
ça vaut ce que ça vaut si vous voulez
c'est à dire que c'est de la
communication encore une fois c'est à
dire vous avez un patron de fait qui
sait très bien qu'ils ne peut pas monter
les taux qui ne peut pas arrêter
finalement d'acheter de la dette
américaine parce que il n'ya qu'eux y a
que lui qui peut le faire aujourd'hui et
qui sont obligés de fonctionner sur un
le refinancement de la dette en ciel et
de la dette nouvelle qui est qui est
émise et qu'il fait un petit tour dans
les dents les prix marais d'isle earth
les banques les banques principales
américaine et qui reviennent vite au
chaud dans les coffres de la banque
centrale donc évidemment il est obligé
de jongler avec ça en permanence et
c'est de la coque est ce que la
situation est inquiétante parce qu'on
vous dit qu'on est dans un déclassement
de l'économie américaine depuis
plusieurs années ça veut dire quoi que
la situation n'est pas plus inquiétants
qu'hier finalement allons elle est peu
plus inquiétante hier c'est à dire que
vous avez une poursuite continue du
d'une amérique qui est en train de tous
les autres pays occidentaux qui est en
train de parce qu'elle a eu un modèle
qui était je vous dis en effet basé sur
la dette parce qu'elle a une démographie
qui est en berne parce que vous avez une
amérique qui est en train de se
déclasser gentiment et et évidemment des
pays des pays des pays asiatiques pas
forcément d'ailleurs la chine mais
d'autres qui sont en train de qui sont
en train de monter et qui se
redresseront probablement beaucoup plus
vite que le fera les que ne le font les
états unis donc voilà après il n'y a pas
eu vraiment de 2,2
de changement je dirais avec le comines
le vide a accéléré le que vida a
montré ce qui s'était passé depuis douze
ans depuis 12 ans vous avez
les tous les problèmes qui ont été
passés sous le tapis et ils sont en
train de ressortir à l'occasion du
comité invite à vous êtes d'accord
notamment sur le déclassement de
l'économie américaine c'est d'un point
de vue macroéconomique on peut dire que
oui ça va pas très bien et c'est passé
c'est pas la crise c'est vrai c'est un
phénomène qui est structurelle en
revanche jusqu'à un déclassement jeu je
n'aurais pas jusque là parce que je suis
pas sûr que ça ait mieux ailleurs et les
etats unis restent quand même en pointe
sur les gros secteurs d'avenir sur les
biotechnologies sur les sciences
cognitives sur l'informatique donc je
dirais que les états unis ça va pas trop
mais la californie ça va toujours bien
mais oui sur sur le reste olivia raison
s'est passé pas un problème de crise c
est un problème c'est un problème
structurel qui vient de taux très bas et
d'une économie qui en fait en surchauffe
parce qu'on l'alimentent avec de la
dette la semaine du 15 décembre le pays
a évité de peu le défaut de paiement le
congrès a accepté de relever le plafond
de la dette du pays une mesure sans quoi
les états unis n'auraient plus été en
mesure d'honorer elle ses créanciers en
gros le pays aurait été placée en défaut
de paiement le texte adopté permet de
relever la limite d'endettement du pays
un peu plus de 31 mille milliards de
dollars ce qui permettra donc au pays
d'honorer ses paiements jusqu'au début
de l'année 2023 pierre bentata est ce
que c'est une situation inédite pour une
première puissance mondiale ou au
contraire est-ce que c'est juste une
formalité de relever le plafond de la
dette et enfin qu'est ce que ça signifie
concrètement être en défaut de paiement
alors oui c'est une forme c'est disons
qu'on remonte les plafonds donc ça c'est
toujours étonnant où on se dit un
problème mais et 2 comme on le disait ça
rien d'inédit normalement quand vous
avez offert une expérience de pensée
imaginons que l'argent que les gens
utilisent quand ils s'endettent soit de
l'argent qui est prêté par d'autres dans
un monde normal c'est comme ça que ça se
passerait et donc du coup vous avez des
entreprises qui investissent des ménages
qui sont endettés et du coup qui
consomment moins à ce moment là parce
qu'ils ont prêté de l'argent on a des
tours de production des investissements
puis on reprend une fois que les biens
arrivent les consommateurs eux qui
avaient épargné et récupèrent leur
argent et consomment sauf que comme on a
des taux qui sont bas maintenus par la
fed en fait les consommateurs
s'endettent pour consommer au moment où
des entreprises investissent donc il ya
nécessairement un effet de surchauffe on
produit on consomme plus que ce qui
existe et donc il faut l'alimenter par
de la dette donc régulièrement il
faudrait augmenter c'est une forme de de
japonisation de l'économie ça a rien de
surprenant parce qu'on vit comme ça
depuis longtemps et principalement
depuis les années 2000 et dans le monde
entier après qu'est ce que ça veut dire
un défaut de paiement c'est pour ça que
ça ça peut pas arriver aux états unis
d'abord parce qu'il utilise du dollar et
que le et que pour l'instant rôle
utilisent tous mais un défaut de
paiement bien c'est grave ça veut dire
un pays en faillite
aux états unis ça veut dire que si le
plafond de la dette n'avait pas été
relevé non mais ça veut dire que
mécaniquement il va être relevé que de
toute façon dont on court on y aura un
consentement à continuer à aller à les
prêter de l'argent ou aller acheter des
obligations il est tout ce qui peut être
émis par les américains tant que de
toute façon on utilise cette monnaie
qu'on est sur les marchés financiers
aussi dépendants d'eux est aujourd'hui
nos marchés financiers sont très
dépendantes de la fed donc ça peut pas
rire on peut pas arriver à la situation
argentine disons mais par contre si ça
devait arriver bon là c'est la
catastrophe c'est pour ça qu'on fera
tout pour l'empêcher puisque vous me
demandez un état en faillite un état en
faillite ça veut dire tous les services
publics qui s'arrête j'ai jour au
lendemain alors ça commence bon
historiquement d'or ça commence par les
eaux on arrête de financer les eaux les
animaux meurent donc vous savez que là
il ya un vrai problème et puis après
c'est les pompiers l'hôpital l'école est
donc là là c'est la catastrophe
voici la comédie je dirais annuelle 1
donc tous les ans on se fait peur au
mois deux hommes commencent en général
au mois de septembre a en parlé en
disant ou la lavande et concis jamais
il ne relève pas le plafond et bien ça y
est c'est la fin les états unis seront
en défaut de paiement on se fait peur
pendant deux mois trois mois et puis
comme par hasard à la dernière minute à
la dernière seconde vous savez pas ce
qui arrive eh bien il relève le plafond
de la dette est là en général qu'est ce
qui se passe ben c'est le mois de
décembre ça tombe bien et donc les
marchés font ou ce qu'on s'est fait peur
à et donc monte parce que parce que on a
eu quand même très on a été très très
inquiet pendant plusieurs mois c'est un
événement c'est un non événement c'est
systématiquement c'est systématiquement
relever parce que les les gens qui
votent ces lois sont aussi des
fonctionnaires et donc ils n'ont pas du
tout envie qu'on leur paye pas leur leur
leur moi donc qu'est ce que vous voulez
qu'il fasse évidemment il file ils le
font et évidemment ils vont pas mettre
les états unis dans une situation de 2,2
de non paiement
donc c'est c'est juste de la comisca
impliquerait pour l'économie mondiale un
pays comme les etats-unis en défaut de
paiement
on sait pas bien parce qu'on n'a pas
personne n'a envie de voir ce que ça
pourrait donner donc
mais mais ça serait ça serait une
catastrophe
c'est à dire vous auriez les monnaies
qui s'écroule partout où vous auriez
mais enfin cesser c'est la suite logique
de ce qui est en train de se passer ceci
dit rien et c'est bien pour ça
aujourd'hui que personne ne peut revenir
en arrière c'est à dire que quand vous
entendez ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure quand vous entendez monsieur
powell qui nous dit oui alors on va
monter les taux oui mais on va arrêter
les achats de quantitative easing c'est
de la com c'est une blague il ne peut
pas le faire et il le sait très bien
d'ailleurs et donc vous aviez eu
souvenez vous fin 2018 un essai comme ça
déjà de de monsieur peau elle qui venait
de qui venait d'arriver et et qui en
2018 nous annonce que le taux normatif
ces trois et demi
et qui un mois après dit excusez moi je
me suis trompé ou vous m'avez mal
interprété afa bon non j'ai pas du tout
l'intention d'arrêter mes achats je vais
même en mettre un petit peu plus et puis
j'ai pas du tout non plus l'intention de
monter les taux et on va lire baisser
mes fils a donc c'est ce qui se passera
là exactement donc c'est de la com c'est
parce que ils sont coincés ils le savent
ils peuvent pas le dire qu'ils sont
coincés et donc qu'ils essaient de
manager la chose
assis entre deux chaises entre est en
train d'essayer de faire comprendre aux
marchés que bon ça serait bien qu'on
freine un peu mais on peut pas le faire
donc qu'on va faire semblant d'essayer
de le faire et puis on va se rétracter
un mois après c'est juste elik hull en
fait merci olivier messiaen on va
marquer une courte pause et on revient
dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine
l'économie américaine avec pierre
bentata maître de conférences à
l'université aix marseille
on va regarder à présent l inflation
elle s'établit à
6,8 pour cent sur un an jamais le pays
n'avait atteint ce taux depuis juin 1989
les moteurs de cette inflation demeure
inchangé il s'agit notamment du prix du
logement de la forte demande des
consommateurs et des perturbations
subies par les chaînes de production a
expliqué un responsable d'axa im à nos
confrères du figaro le patron de la fed
lui a reconnu que la poussée
inflationniste ne pouvait plus être
considérée comme transitoire tu ne tires
bentata pendant qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que ça signifie concrètement quels
waquet lesquels et qu'elle va durer
cette inflation oui elle est due elle
est due à ce phénomène elle est due à
deux phénomènes elle est due à un
phénomène de surchauffe et un phénomène
qui est de l'argent sur les marchés
financiers qui sont utilisés pour
spéculer sur des matières premières mais
du coup il ya un double problème les
prix augmentent sur les matières
premières et il ya un excès de demande
alors que des entreprises ont investi
parce qu on a fait croire aux chefs
d'entreprise que des taux bas ça voulait
dire qu'il fallait qu'ils produisent
plus demain et du coup on se retrouve
avec une économie qui en surchauffe et
ça ça peut pas s'arrêter
enfin sauf à augmenter les taux mais
sinon ça peut pas s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain il faut que les gens endettés
commencent à se désendetter il faut que
des entreprises qui ont trop produite
commencent à s'apercevoir qu'elles ont
trop produits qu'elles perdent de
l'argent qu'elles commencent à licencier
pour que tout ça ralentissent et à ce
moment là pendant ce laps de temps la
fête peut rien faire et au moment où ça
arrive la fête peut que faire une chose
s'est relancé donc ils sont coincés dans
une situation mais comme nous d'ailleurs
où chaque fois que la croissance
ralentit parce que l'économie était en
surchauffe il faut réamorcer la pompe et
on peut jamais assainir le système alors
justement les cadres de la fed se sont
réunis le 15 décembre pour la dernière
réunion de politique monétaire de
l'année 2021 avec au menu un plan anti
inflation à l'issue de cette réunion est
la fed a annoncé le retrait accéléré de
son soutien à l'économie avait donc
avancer de quelques mois la fin de la
réduction d'achat aide active ce ne sera
plus en juin comme initialement prévu
mais en mars lorsque les achats sur
m'ont ramené à zéro il ne devrait pas y
avoir besoin de longs délais avant la
première hausse des taux fois déclaré
jérôme pauwels le patron de la fed ainsi
trois hausses de taux sont envisagés en
2022 mais la remontée de ces taux
dépendra du marché l'emploi olivier je
vous enjoins rigoler c'est une stratégie
sans surprise s'il stratégie sans
surprise en fait c'est l'eau c'est
l'arroseur arrosé quoi si vous voulez
c'est à dire que comme le disais à
l'instant pierse et
vous vous mettez
d'aider des milliers de milliards sur
les marchés boursiers les marchés
boursiers qu'est ce qu'ils font et bien
il achètent aussi des matières premières
parce que elles sont toutes kotthaus
avait qu'on a même côté un contrat sur
l'eau parce qu'on a trouvé ça
intelligent donc
on compte aujourd'hui donc après on
s'étonne et on regarde sa montre bah oui
mais il ya tellement de milliards que ça
va sur n'importe quoi et donc
aujourd'hui il est il est bien embêté
parce que le les marchés boursiers ne
tiennent que par les injections de
liquidités mais pas de bol ça va sur des
trucs sur lesquels ça ne devrait pas
aller c'est-à-dire les matières
premières et qui font flamber
l'inflation est ce que moi alors j'ai un
petit
sur le sur le mot surchauffe je crois
pas qu'ils aient de surchauffe en fait
de d'activité je pense qu'il ya une
désorganisation des chaînes de
production qui ont fait que évidemment
ça coince ça fait des goulots
d'étranglement et donc ça fait des prix
qui montent mais on peut pas parler de
surchauffe d'activité parce que ça
voudrait dire qu'il ya une demande
extraordinaire or la demande pour
l'instant je la vois pas trop ni dans
par exemple les ventes au détail au
moment de deux sexes living et 2 et 2 et
du black friday on voit pas que il ya
une surchauffe là dessus mais simplement
en effet il ya des goulots
d'étranglement qui font que dans un
monde à stoke 0 dans un monde en flux
directs et bien vous avez dès que ça
coince quelque part évidemment vous avez
des hausses de prix donc c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer avec le co
vide ça ça va durer le temps que ça
durera c'est à dire le temps que les
chaînes se réorganise le temps que
l'ailier un arrêt de cette folie
kovy distincts et donc qui vous bloque
un port parce qu'il ya un gars qui
renifle est donc évidemment ça ça va
s'arrêter en revanche là où ils ont un
problème c'est que soit ils continuent à
mettre de l'argent est là vous aurez une
poursuite de la hausse des prix des
matières premières soit ils s'arrêtent
de mettre de l'argent mais à ce moment
là tout va se casser la figure et pas
que les matières premières et ça et
aujourd'hui les banques centrales sont
pas prêtes à ça donc et c'est ce que je
vous disais ils ont le cul entre deux
chaises et puis ils doivent manager ça
avec de la com et mais comme aujourd'hui
on est dans un mine de com de toute
façon un comme politiques comme des des
banques centrales et et on va continuer
très probablement longtemps comme ça une
réaction sur ce que aux annonces de la
fed
il me semble qu'on en avait déjà parlé
ici je vous disais c'est en fait c'est
ce qui compte c'est le message il faut
essayer de leur expliquer aux
entreprises qui à elle de bonne foi
réagissent à des signaux du marché qui
en fait sont pas du marché mais de la
banque centrale que ce sont trop emballé
mais en même temps on peut on ne peut
pas faire plus que ça donc on est dans
une situation qui est une situation faut
tenter d'informer de jouer en fait le
rôle que joue normalement les prix du
marché il faut le jouer simplement en
expliquant aux entreprises mais ça c'est
très compliqué parce que ce qui fait
l'efficacité d'un marché normalement
c'est justement on a besoin d'expliquer
rien à personne les gens regardent les
prix en fonction des évolutions
réagissent là comme ça ça marche plus
parce que le signal est complètement
brouillé parce qu'on a fixés
artificiellement des prix notamment le
taux d'intérêt il faut essayer
d'expliquer aux gens ce qui se passe
tout en leur disant ne vous inquiétez
pas et on va pas on va pas arriver
jusqu'à l'endroit qu'on vous annonce
donc passé c'est que si on a une
économie qui devient quasiment
administrés complètement mais là
concrètement avec
la fin de la réduction des achats
d'actifs avec
2,3 hausse de taux en 2022 ça veut dire
quoi clair que l'inflation va réussir à
la maîtriser ou ça va encore prendre
c'est face et c'est une sorte de jeu
d'apprentis sorciers parce qu'il faut
augmenter les taux suffisamment pour
limiter l'inflation sans que en même
temps ça crée une surcharge de la dette
est trop important quelle proportion ils
sont c'est en fait c c c c impossible de
savoir de tout de suite et du coup c'est
pour ça qu'il faut l'annoncer en
espérant qu'il y ait des réactions avant
qu'ils faillent vraiment les b c diminué
ses dépenses et augmenter les taux et
c'est pour ça que même là les baisses de
dépenses à sont assez faibles on a dû de
l'ordre de 30 milliards notamment sur
des crédits hypothécaires donc on
continue à faire exactement la même
chose qu'on faisait en 2006 2007 avec la
crise des subprimes ont donc on verra
moi je pense que les taux vont augmenter
de façon très faible et à condition
seulement que l'inflation se poursuivre
si elle reste sable je vois même pas
pourquoi
ben jeter un oeil au marché de l'emploi
à présent avec des embauches qui
ralentissent de son dix mille emplois
ont été créés en novembre 2021 contre
570 mille en octobre c'est bien moins
que ce qui était attendu mauvaise
nouvelle pour joe biden olivier et qui a
fait de l'emploi une une de ses
priorités et le variant omikron qui par
dessus le marché pourraient aussi
compliquer la donne sur le front oui
alors bon vous savez ce que je pense des
chiffres de l'emploi américain mais mais
c'est surtout que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour bayonne mais c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour powell puisque
ilâha illâ
conditionna lisez en fait ça ça ça ces
hausses de taux et et son son
l'arête ses achats de dette aux chiffres
du chômage donc il a tout intérêt lui
est ce que les chiffres du chômage soit
pas bon pour repousser cette échéance
donc voilà enfin je veux dire c'est
un petit jeu qui
je dirais ne devrait tromper personne
moi ce qui me
paraît intéressant c est là où on voit
que justement ça
c'est plus ou moins de la comédie
regardez les taux longs américains ils
n'ont pas bougé ils sont prêts à bouger
on est à 1 40 donc si vraiment les
marchés s'attendaient à ce qu'il y ait
des hausses de taux successives au en
2022 je pense que les taux longs
américains se seraient supérieures à
sacy aussi les marchés croyez que ça
allait si bien que ça aux états unis
qu'on était proche du plein emploi qu'on
avait une activité extraordinaire je
pense que les taux d'intérêt ne serait
toujours pas 1,40 donc ça prouve bien
que les marchés eux mêmes savent très
bien que il va rien se passer en gros
seins c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est ce
qui vous annonce donc
regarder le marché actions qui continue
imperturbablement et
quand vous avez des chiffres normalement
les chiffres du black friday aurait dû
faire baisser les marchés et les faire
baisser profondément parce que ça veut
ça peut bien dire ça ne tient que là
dessus le rappelez vous quand même que
le pib américain a
ou deux tiers est constitué de la
consommation des ménages si les ménages
ne consomme plus à ce moment-là ça veut
dire que le pib il va en prendre un
sacré coup dans le nez sur le dernier
trimestre donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que normalement on aurait dû avoir
quand même un impact sur sur les marchés
zéro impact zéro impact pourquoi parce
que le marché sait très bien qu'il ya la
banque centrale qui est derrière donc
c'est pas la peine d'aller en face de la
banque centrale puisque comme le dit
pierre les prix sont administrés nous ne
sommes plus dans des marchés nous sommes
dans des des débuts un régime de prix
administrés et donc à ce moment là vous
savez pouvez y aller ne vous n'avez
aucun risque toute dernière la
conclusion pierre venkata chose oui
juste que c'est fondamental et on n'en
parle pas assez souvent les économistes
ce rebond font pas un très bon travail
dessus mais
c'est assez difficile c'est contre
intuitif mais jouer sur le taux
d'intérêt ça a vraiment un impact sur du
très long terme parce que c'est le prix
du temps c'est le prix que un chef
d'entreprise va observer pour savoir si
c'est rentable d'investir donc à partir
du moment où on a bloqué ce prix là où
on a triché en fait sur cette valeur on
a transformé toutes les prévisions des
gens à long terme et on est coincé dans
une situation pareille soit on accepte
une crise qui va assainir le système et
on repart avec des prix libres et donc
des anticipations qui sont logiques soit
on continue comme ça on sait pas où ça
ou comment on va comment ça va finir
c'est tout le problème merci beaucoup
monsieur on passe aux commentaires cash
un seul commentaire olivier cette
semaine celui d'antoine favre pourquoi
l'économie et la finance vont mal car il
n'y a pas de réel contrôle non ce n'est
pas une question de contrôle c'est une
question de au contraire là il ya là un
contrôle total puisque on vient d'en
parler il ya même un contrôle des prix
et donc il n'y a plus de marché et donc
au contraire vous avez un excès de
contrôle puisque on laisse plus jouer
les les une économie de marché on laisse
plus on laisse plus les prix se former
eux-mêmes et et on vous fixe les prix
donc il ya absolument c'est pas un
défaut de contrôle c'est simplement
qu'on a fait de de mauvaises analyses il
ya 20 ans
qu'on a fait en d'encore plus mauvaise
analyse il ya 13 ans et est que et qu'à
ce moment là et bien on a fait des on a
fait des erreurs qui aujourd'hui comme
le disait pierre tout à l'heure sont
irrattrapables c'est à dire qu'on n'a
pas de plan b on a pas de retour en
arrière possible on est obligé de
d'avoir cette perpétuelle fuite en avant
et que malheureusement on est beaucoup à
ceux à se dire que ça va se terminer mal
mais
mais qu'on n'a pas vraiment la main sur
sur ce qui se passe merci olivier merci
beaucoup pierre bentata d'avoir été
parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université aix marseille
c'est donc la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez
vous la semaine prochaine en attendant
on vous souhaite une très belle année
chez olivier le dernier mot
le premier mot de l'année j'ai
l'impression que dans sa dernière
interview monsieur mac ronde de se poser
la question d'où va la france moi je
peux lui répondre dans le mur
et où vont les états unis ben
économiquement dans le mur aussi
bonne année tout de même